maybe this will turn in magnus's favor
but it feels like an unnecessary gamble
suddenly he is actually offering upper
pawn for free um white's knight has just
gone and taken a pawn and look at this
from magnus he didn't even see that this
pawn was hanging i thought this was part
of his plan a sacrifice but no he's just
blunted a pawn for free and not only is
that not only is that a pawn but that
white knight now is super strong it can
go and take another pawn
it was just a moment of madness from
magnus
it's just a moment of chest blindness we
all have this occasionally kind of a
blind spot that we don't notice and wow
for free
well he's definitely uh giving it away
he he did not see that no poker face no
poker race
but somehow
it doesn't feel like black's position is
that critical even though he's dropped
potentially two pawns because i'm just
taking a look at uh there were
consequences and the big consequence is
that lines have been opened for the
bishops to work their magic
and
black does have a threat